[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this video i'm going
to be giving you guys a piece of pretty
uh pretty neat software that i think my
audience will be interested in
because a lot of my audience is actually
other tech reviewers and software
posters who actually post videos uh
frequently and would like some
alternative to the youtube uploading uh
the youtube uploading way uh now this
happens to be another piece of freeware
that i'm deciding to show you guys a
free youtube uploader that's actually
available here at
dvdvideosoft.com and uh this is actually
part of a giant uh kit of freeware that
i'm going to be going over a lot like
i've been showing you guys
and all you have to do is just click on
freeware just updated and click on
download free studio entirely and you
can get this whole pack
so once you've downloaded this whole
pack of freeware you'll come up with
this studio manager and you can click on
number eight
which will take you directly to a
download link of the youtube uploader so
let's open up the youtube uploader here
i clicked on it and it'll start opening
up now
and uh the youtube uploader does take a
little bit longer to open up than the
other pieces of freeware but i think
it's worth the wait so let's just give
it a wait here and here it is
so in order to upload a youtube video
obviously you must be signed in so i'm
just going to
put in my username and password real
quick
and i'm going to tell it to remember me
since i don't want to have to sign in
every single time
so first of all we're going to find a
video we want to upload to youtube um
i'm just going to go ahead and find a
random video this happens to be a video
i don't you know i don't feel like
uploading a video right now
but it's a seven second video you enter
the title of your video so it could be
hd
tutorial
[Music]
and any tags that we want to put in the
video which is just like youtube tags so
tag one tag two
tag three etc they would all be in the
tags box and then you would go ahead and
put in your description of the video
right here
and last but not least you can go ahead
and select a film category all of the
same film categories that are on youtube
are here available in the film category
or video category section
go ahead and select your category and
i'm going to hit the remember button
because actually most of the videos i
upload to youtube are in the science and
text section
then all you got to do is hit that
upload button right there now i'm not
going to press it
because i don't want to upload that
video but uploading it to youtube just
by hitting that button is really really
fast
in my opinion it's faster than the
actual youtube uploading process in fact
i'll go ahead and show you since i can
go ahead and delete it just hit the
upload button and it'll tell you in
terms of percentage how uh how many
percent it has been uploaded and you can
go ahead and select high priority to
speed things up a bit so i'm just going
to stop the upload so that is basically
it that is how you um you use the free
youtube uploader is way faster than
actual youtube uploading for me uh in
google chrome my my you know 80 90
megabyte tutorials take about four
minutes to upload uh whereas in here it
takes about a minute and a half
so it's really really nice that they let
you do that
so anyway i hope you guys enjoy this
tutorial if you do upload a lot of
videos you might want to check it out
again the dvd video soft link is in the
description and that is basically it so
thanks for watching guys peace